have you heard of uh uh doctors like dr
sebi yes why do i kill all holistic
doctors
right messing up the medical injuries
you short stopping that grind why do
[ __ ] get killed for hustling in front
of a [ __ ] spot
four years ago this month that dr
gonzalez was found dead
um and uh there was no indication that
he had any any uh health problems
they were paying scientists doctors were
smoking
and your dad came along with your with
your son
and um nipsey or some some um like
hip-hop artist
was uh in america but unfortunately this
is also the land of junk food you want
fast food convenience food
fake food of all different kinds it's
everywhere you go you get hit with
messages to eat it
greens and peas how you guys doing
welcome to the dean show and i got the
guru of health
former you like that one jim how you
doing
i'm doing great eddie good to see you
again i can see you because you have you
know black belts and you have grand
masters
i consider you the grand master of
nutrition
former chief nutritionist for dr mccola
at his uh optimal wellness center when
we were uh one of the busiest
nutrition-based health centers in the
country because of the popularity of his
website so you know strangers to the
dean show we've had you on many times i
want to start off with the story
um and it was when i called you about a
year ago
and you've been kind of uh you know
educating a lot of the viewers and
and you've been in this field for almost
going on almost what
over 30 close to 40 years now well i've
been doing
nutrition and health educating on a
professional level since 1985.
so 34 years 34 years i called you up
and i wanted to get your advice i'm at
the airport i'm about to
hit a flight and and i usually opt out
of the the full body scanners and it can
kind of be uh
uncomfortable because you're the only
one opting out there's thousand
you know people you can imagine there's
thousands of people going through the
lines and you're the only one
that's pushes you know his hand up and
says i'd like to opt out
you're doing you're doing the healthy
thing so i called you and i was like it
was one of those where
sometimes you're rushing you don't want
to go through it am i just being
paranoid
so i i was about to not opt out and
there's been times when i when i just
went through it because you know i'm
running late
and i i don't wanna there's a big line
and now you gotta wait for someone to
come and pat you down
so i called you up and we all need this
motivation sometimes so i called you say
hey what should i do
i wanted to get your your advice i
thought maybe i'm being overly paranoid
and then um come to know because that
has to do with the scanners europe
banned europe had is now officially they
banned those
body scanners yeah i wasn't aware of
that but uh what do you think about that
one
i think that's that's healthy but every
time i asked every time i'd ask the
people when i get opt-out
i say you know i say hey this is for
health purposes i want to protect and
honor my body you know
you didn't mention what my advice to you
was yeah that's why once you get into a
world well
you tell the viewers oh yeah from my
advice to you go ahead
well i said don't don't allow yourself
to be zapped
don't allow yourself to be zapped no
it's have your just
accept the uh the conventional pat down
you know let them let them frisk you and
but uh don't don't allow yourself to be
zapped
yeah you told me to get opt out yeah
pretty much yeah
yeah well um i i haven't uh done uh
airline travel since uh 2010 was the
last time i did it for my own
uh for my own values um i just
refused to submit myself to being
treated like a criminal
to have to board um you know a a jet
but i understand you know i many people
including dr grassle and dr
garcia travel a lot you know it's
traveling is not is not important for my
lifestyle for many people it is
you know um and i can i can appreciate
that
but um you know it's um
uh it is um a situation has been for a
long time
now um that uh you're required
to submit yourself to be in
um if not zapped then frisk and searched
as if you are a criminal
and um
i just will not um submit myself
um but then again as i said traveling is
not important for my lifestyle but if it
is important for your lifestyle i think
the healthier option is to just
let someone frisk you let someone you
know
do a you know manual search rather than
than zapping yourself because at the
very least that's another way that your
biology will be stressed
why would they ban it there but not ban
it here
higher level of consciousness higher
level of concern for
you know the realities of what they're
subjecting people to
so didn't europe also ban gmos at most
of europe
they don't with monsanto but over here
we let it go well
um they started here of course um they
were
the um the genetically modified crops
that were made to be
compatible with the poison known as uh
glycosate which uh the commercial name
is roundup ready
it is a poison and anytime you're
killing something whether you're killing
weeds or whether you're killing
bugs whether you're killing
bacteria anytime you're killing any type
of living organism
obviously you need to have a poisoning
effect and so
um they started in this country
and they've been pushed very heavily
in other countries like you mentioned
europe i don't um
i don't know specifically what the
policy is in the european union
but it's not as prevalent and i think
it's
there's very little of it actually going
on in
in countries like russia
in fact um i wasn't uh i wasn't prepared
to uh to specifically discuss this issue
but
um i think if you uh if you if you look
it up you'd find that
united states of america is is basically
gmo and glycosate central
yeah it's interesting that you know in a
lot of the popular
brands you have the um
the ewg environmental working group
yes exactly and then they they release
some new studies and they found that
the level that would be acceptable of i
mean i would just think like any kind of
you drink some water and you know that
there's
any someone urinates just a little urine
comes in your water
no one's going to drink that if you
think about it someone put some poison
in your cereal
kids cereal but they found uh
the was it the ewg uh and
one in the studies that in the major
brands of quaker oats and you have some
of these uh like honey nut cheerios
natural valley
uh chocolate peanut butter cheerios and
the list goes on
that they had 230 times
greater amount exposure level
in monsanto's roundup the glycosate
and this is carcinogen this can actually
lead to cancer
they have it in these kids cereals yeah
that's crazy well
it's um it's being found
in uh in basically all aspects of of the
environment and the
in the marketplace because there are
there are uh thousands i think it was
it's even appropriate to to to mention
millions of tons of this stuff
are sprayed every year in this country
yeah and so
um you know um uh
human beings um
need to remember um
very very important this is something
that native american culture tried to
teach
um the the white man
the the european um uh people
uh in this country in the 19th century
um
what they tried to teach um the um
uh uh the the the the white people
um uh is a basic truth about
life on this planet which is this
whatever you do to the earth
you ultimately do to yourself you cannot
pollute
the air you breathe without ultimately
polluting yourself you cannot pollute
the water that you that you consume
without polluting yourself you cannot
pollute the land in which you grow your
food without polluting yourself
there was appreciation um about the web
of life
and how um again whatever you do to the
earth
you ultimately do to yourself yeah and
so
this is so fundamentally important to be
aware of and
and if you have this awareness i think
naturally with that awareness comes a
respect
for how you interact with your
environment
and what you do to your environment and
if you understand that if you
if you're if you're generating air
pollution water pollution or
polluting your land and ultimately
you're going to be polluting yourself
i think you're going to be a lot more
conscientious
a lot more conscientious and a lot um
more reluctant to pollute
the environment that you're living in
yeah wow that's like you you're
reminding us of that's what we call the
sunnah the way of the sunnah this is
like uh
the way that we're taught we're taught
that you're to uh not only like you say
develop we should
as human beings develop this nutritional
integrity
uh care for ourselves our environment
for humanity
but when it's uh profits over people
when it comes down when people don't
live for a higher purpose
just for the money becomes their deity
you see yeah they just live for the
dollar
that's very sad when that does happen
yeah but anyway
eddie i want to thank you for mentioning
mentioning one of my favorite
uh phrases and subjects nutritional
integrity yeah
which um i mentioned a lot i got that
from you yes fake food
like the people know i'm always saying
eat real food fake food
uh developing natural nutritional
integrity
this is uh the man we're getting it from
yeah well nutritional integrity
is something that um the world is and uh
very um you're the food
you know the teacher like mufti is like
the bone above the teacher so i say
grand master mufti of the food of the
nutrition
so and and what what is nutritional
integrity all about just
to remind people um of the uh of the
practical meaning
of developing your nutritional integrity
um first of all integrity is basically
all about being honest being honest with
other people being honest
with yourself um and uh when you're
eating
fake food um you know pizza and all kind
of you know
junk you know it's like you're lying to
your body you're putting in when i used
to eat a fake food before i knew butter
you know i was like every time i would
eat
fast food burgers with french fries you
know it was like i was lying to my body
but when you're eating real food you're
being honest with your body
you're honoring your body's biological
needs for for real nutrition but so
nutritional integrity is all about
not only being honest with your body but
specifically it's all about
setting standards for what is acceptable
real food and drink for your body and
then being faithful
to those standards that you set for
yourself rather than
eating like what i grew up eating and
what what what i think
is very common for for people that grow
up in america you know the first 20
years of my life i grew up eating the
anything goes diet
you know the anything goes diet is you
know you're hungry
and um you eat whatever whatever it
doesn't matter you have no standards
it's just whatever whatever
you have a taste for whatever's most
convenient with other whatever
other people are eating around you in a
social situation
with basically no attention to to
nutrition
you know i grew up eating the anything
goes diet and i suffered for it i
you know the very first time i was on
the dean show i talked about how
the reason i started studying nutrition
in 1977 at the age of 20 was because i
reached a point in my life where i was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
all the time
you know the anything goes diet had
taken its toll on me
and um we all have our tolerance for how
much
nutritional abuse uh our body can take
some people
you know it takes a lot longer before it
starts causing their their their body to
start breaking down in various ways with
me
i think in retrospect it was a blessing
that you know i suffered so much
at a relatively young age and then you
know started waking up
uh you know 42 years ago at the age of
20 and
that was the beginning of me you know
that's what kicked off where you're at
today that was the catalyst well where
i've been for a long time yeah you know
i went from being um
sick and tired of being sick and tired
all the time to you know
achieving and sustaining a very high
level of health
for many many are you the guy from the
the juice man juice the you know the guy
who's
you know he's glowing from all the
juicing you know the guy
uh he's talking about uh uh jay cordish
uh
juice man juice mad yeah yeah god bless
him he died
he died a few years ago at the age of i
think he was 90 something no i'm joking
that's not you but he's uh
you're not just into uh also juicing but
just eating real food really eating
healthy food how do you deal with when
someone because you're really into um
eggs like that's one form of nutrition
and
but many people now when you bring this
up they're really worried about the
cholesterol the fat
in the eggs and then it's a it's it's
something that
scares people like too many eggs you
have a heart attack
what do you say to that um it's possible
to over consume
any particular nutrient
cholesterol is a nutrient your body
naturally makes it
it's essential for life and
it's possible to over consume fat what i
see
people over consuming far more commonly
though
when i work with them especially
indications of this
in in blood test results is the most
common over consumption is the over
consumption of carbohydrates
especially processed sugars and
processed starches
didn't you have the sugar industry
actually paid off
they end up paying off and they started
to blame fat did they this was uncovered
that the scientists they were
you know about this right yeah yeah so
um any any time you're over consuming
uh any nutrient that can have value for
your body if you're over consuming
protein fats or carbohydrates
especially those those are the the
macronutrients that's where we get our
calories those are also
used as building blocks for our body
but any time you're over consuming
something that
is essential for your biology the very
first consequence is going to be
it's going to hurt your energy so you
know
in regard to your nutritional practices
and other self-care practices you always
need to correlate
your practices with your with your
current level of health
you know if um if you're in really good
health if you have
if you experience peaceful energy
relaxed alertness emotional poise
positive stable mood great mental
clarity your digestion and elimination
is good you sleep well at night
you know you look good you feel good
you know by all means stick with what
you're doing but if you're not satisfied
with your level of health
if you if you have this nagging feeling
that something is off something is wrong
you need to
you need to change something you need to
add something to your life you need to
subtract something from your life to
make it easier
for your body to be healthier well then
you know i think
one of the things you want to do is take
a very honest
and careful look at what you are what
you have been eating and drinking
and um it's uh it's very likely going to
be appropriate for you to make some some
changes
um but um there is
there are some general nutritional
practices
that are applicable to everybody for
instance the most basic one is eat real
food don't eat
fake food you know yeah i call it that's
the the white build level that's where
everyone needs to start yes and um but
as far as
like you mentioned eggs yes i'm a big
fan of
of egg nutrition especially raw egg
nutrition from healthy chickens as i
demonstrated
on the dean show not too long ago the
consumption of raw egg nutrition warrior
style
and uh last week i brought you um
a supply of uh of fresh eggs from
the uh my my organic farmer connection
where i get my eggs and
and you enjoy those eggs too and and
also
we met the we met uh one of your was he
clients
that actually he had uh crohn's disease
that's right and he's
healed from it yes yes is this
experience is that your full upswing in
his health
is that something where the conventional
medicine will say that's unhealable you
cannot that's
that's not sustainable sustainable the
the but he's
i met him he said he did what yeah is it
right he was a former student of yours
yeah he used to train jiu jitsu also
very nice uh what's his name again yeah
chris
chris very nice uh uh brother very nice
man yes uh he was getting the
um the eggs from and chris is uh has uh
become a wonderful example
of someone who has developed a very high
level of nutritional integrity yeah
and nutrition when you have that it's
like a shield that you
carry with you everywhere you go in the
land of junk food because
you know that's that's one of the the
the ways that um i think it's
appropriate to describe
america america of course is a great
country there's a lot of good things
in america but unfortunately this is
also the land of junk food you want fast
food convenience food
fake food of all different kinds it's
everywhere you go you get hit with
messages to eat it
um on an ongoing basis
um if you're in social situations that's
mostly what dominates and so when you
carry your nutritional integrity with
you
everywhere you go it's like a shield
against the fake food because when it's
like it's been offered to me
many many times over the years i just i
i just smile
and i say thank you but no thank you
here's the confusing part because
the people that are supposed to be there
the respected
physicians who are there when people go
with these problems obesity
diabetes these health concerns they go
to their doctor what you're talking
about
they're not hearing it from the top of
the elite the doctors are supposed to be
the medical doctors the elite people of
health
but they don't address these things that
we're talking about today yeah
the majority what is it like 99 percent
don't address these things there are
adopt
good really good doctors out there like
like dr amadia seed
that you had yeah yeah holistic
uh um she's a holistic uh doctor also
very nutritionally
or educated and minded and and she gives
she
she basically teaches people dr madiha
yes she teaches people how to eat
healthier and how to live healthy
there are doctors like that yes but how
do when people
usually go to the doctor they're not
taught this they're not
sat down they see they've done studies
where
you know you come in and doctors tell us
this also uh they got like seven minutes
to see you like to diagnose the problem
five to seven minutes
yeah that's not going to happen that
fast is it no it takes time to adjust
and then
and then uh so the system has been has
been
has been developed that is conducive to
basically
um writing prescriptions for drugs
and um so that's what does md stand for
well um my friend max says more drugs
as opposed to nd which uh no drugs
and the um is somewhere into a
naturopathic someone else took it to a
higher level it's a master drug dealer
okay well no there are a lot of there
are a lot of good doctors who are taking
it
and we want p uh doctors to take it to
the next level because it's continuing
education that's important so there are
doctors who are limited
who are saying man we are just our hands
are tied right they don't learn
nutrition in medical school they don't
know this
and now they have so many patients to
see and they'll get in trouble if they
don't
fill the quota why aren't you
prescribing these drugs they got three
four hundred thousand they're enslaved
by debt
yeah and they're stuck their hands are
tied it's the people above who are
pulling the strings
that's right eddie yeah yeah it's um uh
the um the doctors who
who uh went to medical school with good
intentions to learn how to help people
um i you know i i i appreciate
that a lot of them uh maintain their
good intentions like my sister my sister
is an md she's a she's an
md she does urgent care pediatric my
sister is certainly a good person
and you know and she um uh
tell us that story that happened with
your sister about you were reading the
blood work
with the sodium or something okay what
happened with that
well now she's a doctor she's a medical
doctor and then well this is this has to
do with uh
the um the knowledge and understanding
that that um i've gained over the years
and uh learning how to make the most of
blood test results
uh as opposed to um uh
most um
medical doctors seem to specialize in
making the least of blood test results
um
in in regards to i just you know back to
my
my days as chief nutritionist at dr
mccola's optimal wellness center and
even before that
i i had heard from many people who
sought out my
my nutrition and health building
guidance and they had they had blood
work
done and usually this the the scenario
went like this someone was not feeling
well
they contacted a doctor
wound up having blood testing and
when it came time for them to find out
about their blood test
results it was very very common for them
to be told that
everything was fine everything is normal
even if
they didn't feel fine and even if they
felt lousy they were told everything was
fine
everything was normal and then they
would show me their blood test results
and i would see from the from the
knowledge and understanding that i have
about blood test interpretation how many
have you over the years read blood tests
oh approximately thousands thousands oh
sure that was
so there was at dr mccullough's optimal
thousands you've read i um i was the guy
who had the responsibility to teach
other practitioners
how to interpret blood test results from
a holistic perspective and from a
nutritional perspective
i was responsible for teaching all of
the other practitioners who needed to
know this
how to do it and how to make the most of
blood test results
helping people to understand their own
blood test results is
is very worthwhile very enjoyable in
fact because most people
don't know anything about their own
blood test results
and i'd like to empower people to at
least have some basic understanding
about what is being measured
and and and what the the measures
are indicating to me with my with my um
knowledge and understanding about how to
make the most of blood choices so just
just to finish this eddie so
you know they were told it's very common
it's like
the vast majority of the time when
people do blood testing
they're told everything is fine
everything is normal again even if they
feel lousy then they
then they show me the same blood test
and i see everything is not fine
everything is not normal
and i see uh very commonly i see
indications to me
that there they've been over consuming
carbohydrates for their metabolism which
will hurt their energy
their under consuming protein is fairly
common i see
indications of stress on their immune
system
which sometimes is related to the fact
that they have
a toxic tooth in their mouth a root
canal treated tooth
which that was an issue that you had
and i see i see other indications on
their blood tests that they have some
weaknesses and imbalances and there's
room for improvement so
getting back to my mom so in
early 2015 my mom who was at that time
was
80 years of age she
she was not doing well she was
her she was losing energy she was
feeling weak and one morning she got out
of bed
and she collapsed and she uh
went to her this is your mother now this
is my mom she went to her doctor
who she'd been connected with for a
while and this doctor did
very comprehensive blood testing on my
mom and
when it came to my mom finding out about
her blood test results my mom was told
everything was fine everything was
normal and then
um my brother called me to let me know
my mom has
blood work in and that um i
i certainly wanted to see it and so i
got over there as soon as i could but
before i got over there my sister who's
an md
and who loves her mother's no question
about that
she looked at my mom's blood test
results and she also told my mom
everything was fine everything was
normal
and i looked at my mom's blood test
results and everything was not fine
everything was not normal in fact for
example
for example well the biggest issue on my
mom's blood test result
was that she had a very low level
of the essential electrolyte in our
blood it's always routinely done in
blood chemistry
um it's her sodium level was
really low it was only 128
and the bottom of the lab reference
range on this particular blood test
was 134 so my mom was well below the
bottom of the lab
reference range it got tagged as low
by the lab and both her medical doctor
and her daughter who's a doctor who
loves her either they didn't
see this they missed it they didn't look
at the blood test results carefully
enough
or they didn't understand the importance
of this but
um there is a specific medical term for
a really low
sodium level and it's a hypo that is low
natremia okay um and so
um if you if you're if your sodium level
in your blood is too low
you'll feel really weak and um
that's what happened to my mom so
anyway there were other issues on my
mom's blood test it wasn't just that
there were a number of other issues
she was deficient in magnesium she had
indications of
some stress on her kidneys and she had a
number of other issues so i gave my mom
recommendations nutritional
recommendations to strengthen her where
she was weak
to balance her where she was out of
balance and
of course you know she being my mom
she doesn't follow all my
recommendations only about half of them
but in three days
my mom was revitalized and and and um
two of the recommendations i gave her
were to do some raw egg smoothies
okay raw egg with like banana and some
strawberries which is just delicious
combination very delicious but she
needed she needed she needed to give her
body more
very high quality protein and fat
nutrition
and when the
protein and fat nutrition are not heat
damaged i i've seen from clinical
experience that there potentially is
greater biological value there so
she did the raw egg smoothies she did
some fresh vegetable juice and i had her
start adding some good quality sea salt
to her food you know to to taste you
know trust trust your own
um you know instinct as far as how much
to use but she obviously needed to get
some
give her body more good quality uh
sodium to work with and
in in three days following half of my
recommendations
she was revitalized and so that was that
was
especially enjoyable for me um to see
that
and to this day my mom is doing very
well considering that now she's going to
be this year
she is going to be 85 in november
yes so how do you get past this when you
have organizations saying that specific
organizations saying that look avocados
are bad for you
but box cereals are good for you who
says avocados are bad for you right you
know
where you have um you know our friend
chris also he
he uh he talks about this where certain
organizations
yeah he mentions even the food and drug
administration you know they'll come out
and they'll warn people this is one
example
uh he's given uh countless times about
avocados because of the fat contact
oh yeah right yeah so now but boxed
cereals
right are are good for you but then you
look back and you uncover you unfold
like an onion right
yeah you don't unfold and then the smell
comes coming it starts the potency
starts coming out you start to see these
layers and layers
why and these are facts this is not
conspiracy or anything where you have
you know scientists who are paid off by
the sugar industry and we know what
sugar they just i'm not talking about
natural sugars
you know found in honey or dates or
whatnot but the sugar
processed refined sugars the fake foods
that's pumped into half a million of the
fake food items out there
and now they start promoting this stuff
right they start fed up is a great
documentary that exposes this also
so now you have these organizations who
are out there supposed to be helping
and guiding humanity now we're actually
getting in most cases bad
advice then it's uncovered that these
scientists just like the nikos teen
industry they were paying
scientists doctors were smoking now you
have this with the sugar industry paying
scientists and now
they're basically lying
right lying and then fully they're
they're promoting uh the fake foods and
saying the good foods that the crater
has given us
you know you should be careful of eating
of like avocados and with the fat kind
of eggs that you keep promoting and
and and things that go more in line with
common sense yeah i especially enjoyed
the egg party we had um
outside of your school last week when i
when i brought the eggs and i brought
some eggs
and your dad came along with your with
your son and
um eggplant and your dad started passing
out eggs
for for everybody to have and we were
all doing the the raw egg nutrition
warrior style except except for you
because
here's a here's a prime example of how
there is no one specific food that is
going to be universally beneficial for
everybody because
it's possible for any given individual
to have an allergy to any given food
which means that your immune system is
is reacting to
um the protein fraction of a food
or or sometimes people food is not right
for someone because they
they can't digest it well like some
people have what is known as lactose
intolerant
and they can't digest that well that
particular
milk sugar well or like someone who eats
beans or legumes
and they get a lot of gas and bloating
from eating
those foods because of the the the type
of carbohydrates that are in those foods
but
in my in my experience when someone is
in need
of enhancing their health building their
health they're not satisfied with their
level of health i've seen
much greater value with raw egg
nutrition of course always from
from healthy um happy chickens not
conventional chickens obviously no not
not from the factory farms that's that's
risky
but um when you're when you're getting
um
organic chickens um that are that are
allowed to
to eat the foods they naturally have the
instinct which is that that is they they
have access to open pastures so they get
to forage for whatever plant foods they
want
and also you know uh they get to eat as
many insects as they can get their beaks
on because that's actually a chicken's
best very best food
best source of protein and essential
fatty acids and vitamin b12
so um you know it's it it's
fundamentally important to really only
eat animal foods from
healthy humanely raised and also you
know um
uh humanely killed animals this is one
of the reasons i have basic appreciation
um for uh hillel did you did you see
what happened recently in indiana
and you're and you're and you're quite
accomplished at doing that properly
because i've seen you in action
especially um
you know at your at uh the the little
farm that you have in in preparation for
a holiday yeah uh did you see recently
what happened they had it on the news
they had an
un uh an organization going undercover
and they were exposing
what is actually going on with many of
these cows these calves you know
the the brutality and yeah the uh yeah
it's it's
you've seen that did you did you well
that's that's nothing new about that
eddie
the the the god-awful conditions of the
commercial factory farms and the feed
lots
has been documented going back over 100
years there was
there was a an investigative journalist
at the i think was the first decade of
the 20th
century he had
written an expose on the realities of
the
commercial factory farm feedlot industry
um uh
oh um um um maybe it'll come to me in a
moment but his his name and the the
title of his book
was uh um uh is
it's not something that's that's coming
to mind right now um
but um uh this is
this is over a hundred years ago was
identified how
really how how about barbaric the the
commercial factory farms or
kids because unfortunately this again
gets back to the issue
of people not having a connection to
um to other other forms of life and it's
just like
you know the as everything got
industrialized and
you know and as the commercial feed lot
beef industry especially got bigger and
bigger and bigger
it was operated with less and less
consciousness
and more and more carelessly and the
animals were just
treated you know more and more
oh just you see inhumanely
yeah this goes back to what you know
that high level we call it taqwa this is
when people i mean
they make um the goal the ultimate goal
is just business money i mean nothing
wrong with business but
there's no integrity you talk about
nutritional integrity i mean it's health
and tech i mean just life integrity that
you're
you have you have um you have good
business ethics you're you're not just
blinded
by the dollar and just you know the the
end goal is the profits the bottom line
yeah and then the bottom line at the end
uh there's another example we've seen
like
they had in all the fitness magazines
that a little bit of
of wine a little bit of uh you know uh
is good for the help but then recently
who uh world health organization they
produce that no amount of alcohol is
good for human consumption
right oh i support that yeah yeah that's
not no amount so
so now you see these facts coming out
but a lot of times you know you go to
again it goes back to
how okay so we gained some wisdom from
from uh that's what we want to derive
uh some of the things we talked about
eating fake food avoiding fake food
we talked about uh the first thing
opting out of uh
dna damage that was banned in europe
right
uh so now it's banned here that's
another good uh piece of advice
uh to go for the pat down the other
thing you had
you had mentioned is blood work it's so
important so how much blood work does
the average
doctor um where would you recommend them
to go then for blood work for
a good reading of blood work a
functional medicine doctor what would
you do yeah you'll get
you you'll be more likely to
to really get some value from from
giving some of your precious blood and
going through the time and expense of
generating blood test results
um but um uh
you're um you're not likely to um
to get much value at all um from from
going through
uh a blood testing process unless you
have
something just really blatant and
glaringly
you know either
way too high or way too low as far as a
blood test value
but um uh i wonder how many
of the the viewers who who are going to
be watching this episode
have experience already in their life
what i call with with some humor
some intentional humor what i call the
big medical blow off in regard to blood
test results
that's when people are told everything
is fine everything is normal
even when they feel lousy and they they
don't feel fine they don't feel so
called so-called normal and then when
someone
who really has some some depth or their
knowledge and understanding about
about what's really being measured on a
blood test and how those particular
measures
will be influenced by self-care
practices
such as what people are eating and
drinking you know when you take the time
to carefully
look at those results after all someone
has given some of their precious blood
and gone through the time and expense to
to generate these these test results
you know uh and if you really understand
what you're looking at and you take the
time
to really carefully look um
i i i teach there's a potential treasure
of of of information there in regard to
what's going on with your basic and
vital blood chemistry
and blood cell values that are being
measured
and there's a there's um
a lot of potential very valuable
information in regards to
um not only where you have problems but
i always enjoy
i've ever since you know i've been
looking at blood test results and
explaining them to people
i always enjoy explaining to people
where they're strong
where you have strength where you have
good balance
and and then also as needed where you're
less than strong where you where you
have room for improvement where you have
some weakness where you have some
imbalance
and um blood test results have helped me
um for for many many years um
uh certainly um you know uh at dr
mccola's
he he he did very comprehensive blood
testing
and uh he was very supportive of of of
all of his practitioners
uh taking the time to make the most of
the results that were generated in fact
we would dedicate at least
one whole session one whole session 45
minutes at least
to explaining blood test results to
people
to help them better understand
themselves and where they're strong
where they're
they're in balance but also where
they're not so strong where they have
some weakness where they
where they have some imbalances and it
was it was a motivating factor for
people
but unfortunately what i would also um
i include in what i call the big medical
blow off with regard to blood test
results is
if a person is not told everything is
fine everything is normal
[Music]
the other most common experience is
they're not told anything at all
about their blood test results nothing
which
gives them the assumption that well
everything must be fine
or or they would have called me um
but um i've i've looked at a number of
blood test results again going back to
my days
even before it was worked for dr mercola
looking at blood test results where the
lab
clearly tagged a particular value
out of the reference range either on the
high side or the low side
and the practitioner that the person did
the blood testing through yeah
didn't even comment on it nothing they
just they just completely
blew it off yeah and i don't that's not
right
that's not right if you're gonna if
you're gonna have someone go through the
time and expense of giving some of their
precious blood to generate results
you know i don't understand why you
wouldn't want to make the most of those
results i think
dr medea seed would would agree with me
and have
a deep appreciation for what i'm saying
i brought up um and this is why i
brought up the alcohol example
was because i think this was in the
lancet that they did this study with um
every 10 seconds someone is dying from
from
alcohol related deaths just like the
sugar industry they ended up paying pain
the scientists to go ahead
and label fat and you know these natural
fats is bad
and then people get you know um scared
from this
uh same thing was going on with the
nicotine industry same thing with the
alcohol industry
they were paying these scientists so
human beings can be bought people who
don't have integrity
who are who worship the dollar let me
ask you something else uh
and i and i'm i guarantee that and this
is a simple change
you see when you get educated right
we're all should be we we call with
people sunnah that people you should be
ready to adjust towards the good and
leave off something
that's of no benefit and then substitute
it with something
that you can have more tremendous
benefit from and protect you and your
family from harm
why do they have and i guarantee
probably 99 of people
are using toothpaste that has fluoride
in it
and their kids but if you just i
challenge you right now if you just take
that toothpaste and you turn
it to the back and read the warning and
it says
if swallowed if more than used for
brushing and the amount that they're
referring to is a pea-sized amount
yeah of toothpaste pay attention not not
an ice cream scoop
amount that is you know you see in the
in the television commercials no they're
referring to
a pea-sized amount of the toothpaste if
more than
is used for brushing that's what it's
the amount they're referring to more
than a pea-sized amount
is accidentally swallowed contact a
poison control center
right away contact poison control that's
that's the acknowledgement go take your
two pace right now
uh yeah on on every game boxer tube take
it out of the toothpaste
you'll see that warning it's it's 99 of
toothpaste out there well
if it's got fluoride in it um which 99
do well that's it's a very common
ingredient
but um this is this is a much
taken for granted acknowledgement that
fluoride
can have a poisoning effect on our body
yeah so now your kids are obviously many
of them are swallowing this stuff
right because they're inadvertently
inadvertently yes and
and and uh it's been definitively proven
definitively proven definitively proven
especially in recent years
harvard school of public health
environmental health
health sciences sciences
it's been definitively proven and
actually
is this is reinforced all the time that
there is a very strong correlation
between the levels of fluoride that
children are consuming
in a child's intelligence specifically
their iq the higher the level of
fluoride that a child is consuming the
lower
their iq why do they put it in this
if this is the risk of damaging one's
intelligence their iq their health
but the argument is there there is just
enough that will strengthen your teeth
and it's not harmful you've heard the
the argument for it
for fluoride yeah oh sure so yeah it's
it's it's
it's a it's a prime example of
propaganda
um because it's not based on science
there's they don't have truth on their
side
but um you know there's there's
big money pushing you know the
fluoridation of water agenda
um oh it goes back to we're talking
about profits over
health over people yeah well you know um
fluoride is the most protected pollutant
in the history of the world
in fact some truth about fluoride beyond
the propaganda that
very few people are familiar with is
that
fluoride is the main pollutant that is
generated
by basically all industries that mine
the earth for raw material fluoride is a
naturally
occurring element in the earth's crust
on the periodic table of elements it's
listed as fluorine
fluorine is the pure element fluorine in
his pure form is a
very caustic very toxic yellowish
gas and it's the most highly reactive
element on the periodic table of
elements
in fact it is so highly reactive pure
fluorine does not occur naturally in the
earth it's always found in combination
with an other element for instance
fluorine when it combines with sodium it
produces sodium fluoride
when it combines with calcium it
produces calcium fluoride
fluoride is not a nutrient for the human
body it is a toxin
and but all major industries that mine
the earth for raw materials like the
aluminum industry the phosphate
fertilizer industry they all generate as
their
primary waste product their pollutant
various types of fluoride compounds
and to make a very long
machiavellian and labyrinthian story
short during world war
ii were the first experiments were done
with fluoridating water
because it was hoped that
um because there was all this fluoride
pollution being generated especially
during the armaments buildup of world
war
ii and there were more and more lawsuits
being filed against
fluoride polluting industries for
the fluoride pollution was was causing
damage to agricultural crops it was
actually
injuring maiming animals that were where
people had farms they were close
to a fluoride pollution generating
industry like an aluminum
manufacturing plant or a phosphate
fertilizer
industry or there's any industry that
that mines
the earth for raw materials is going to
have is going to be generating some
fluoride pollution as
in their refinement
processes they're going to be generating
some fluoride pollution
and so there were more and more lawsuits
being generated are being filed against
these fluorite polluting industries
and so again to make a very long story
short
government and industry basically
conspired and
and that is the right word conspired and
there is
there is evidence proving this they
conspired
to create a new image for fluoride this
is this is how they handled
the ever-increasing number of lawsuits
against
industries that generate fluoride as a
natural pollutant in their extraction
and refinement processes
what they what they decided to do was to
tell people that the fluoride is good
for you it's not a pollutant it doesn't
cause harm
it's good for you in fact it's so good
for you we're going to add it to your
drinking water
and um if you want to get into the
details of this
there was a book that came out this is
the the definitive book
about the the history
the economics the the science
and the politics of fluoride the book
was called
the case against fluoride written by
a chemistry professor by the name of
paul
conan and a couple of his colleagues
the book has hundreds if not
thousands of references for the
information knowledge and understanding
in the book
and the case against fluoride by paul
connet is subtitled
with a very important truth
about fluoride beyond the propaganda and
the subtitle of the case against
fluoride
is called is is how
hazardous waste ended up in our drinking
water
and the bad science and powerful
politics
that keeps it there now you're really
getting on to the truth about
about fluorite and why it's been so
heavily promoted
a lot of these things they're not
they're not hard to uncover you just got
to do a little bit of research
and the facts are there yeah well you
you
you just you gotta you gotta go beyond
the propaganda you gotta start asking
questions
rather than just accepting you know the
mainstream propaganda about anything
you know if you really wanna get
educated ask
questions and go beyond the mainstream
propaganda and that's what that if it's
mainstream
it's a in my experience my life
experience
it's there's much more likely to be
an agenda behind what is being promoted
to the
the public uh it's more likely to be
appropriately con
considered propaganda which is but
propaganda is
is uh the definition of that is this is
um
misleading and highly biased information
um to um
to convince people of
a particular point of view or a
particular
agenda that that someone's trying to
promote
but propaganda is is not used to
represent the truth
and one of the things that i think is uh
is important to um uh to understand
is that um in the history of the story
of
of fluoride is that when the united
states government
um uh decided to um
uh push the fluoridation of water as a
national agenda that started in 1950
isn't it interesting that the person
that they called upon
to help them promote the value of water
fluoridation to the american public
was a man who had actually written a
book in 1928
called propaganda and that man's name is
edward bernays
and edward bernays um is
regarded as the original
spin doctor is one of the names for him
he was one of the
the fundamental developers of the whole
field of public relations
and how to market
successfully to the public how to market
anything to the public and his first
major accomplishment
was the marketing of cigarette smoking
to women in this country in the 1920s
up until 1920 or so there was i think a
very
good very fortunate for the health of
women
social taboo against women smoking in
public
and but edward bernays set about
breaking that taboo
and the way he did that was he made
smoking
look glamorous and sexy
and very attractive
to women he associated cigarette smoking
for women with being independently
minded and all of that
and he very simply what he did was he
paid um
famous women of the day you know
actresses and and performers
socialize well-known women to simply be
photographed
smoking a cigarette in public and it got
marketed to women so that's
part of edward bernays is his background
and
isn't it interesting that the united
states government called upon
him to help them promote
water fluoridation to the american
public beginning
in in the 1950s a man who had written a
book
on propaganda in which i have that book
i've read that book
and he not only justifies the use of
propaganda um but he glorifies it
and our government called on him to help
not a scientist not someone who is uh he
was studying
fluoride but someone who is very highly
accomplished
in the um the field of this is
documented
oh yes this is not some conspiracy no
there's
no this is this is this is actually
addressed in the in the case against
fluoride
yeah um where can people look this up
this case well the case against fluoride
you just google it you
buy it um from any any website that
deals in real books but um you know the
mainstream media did not give
any attention to this book you know they
the authors of the book uh case against
fluoride were hoping
that this the book would be a game
changer because it's so
well documented and it's an academic
study
oh yes yes yes and the the thing is um
uh the promoters of of of water
fluoridation
they have never had and they will never
have
science and truth on their side no they
don't
the case against fluoride they have
they have science and truth on their
side but you know what you know what the
promoters of fluoride have on their side
they have big money big money and they
have they have
um political connections on their side
they've got they've got the economic
and the political power and authority
status with the public
that goes back with most of these things
we're talking about yeah
when money gets involved now you have
some power and then you're able to
distort the truth
what do you think of and i'll tell you
why i'm bringing this up have you heard
of uh
doctors like dr sebi yes i don't know
much about him
personally i've heard about him people
have brought him out anytime i talk
about health i've always someone will
come up have you checked out dr sebi
i did a little bit of research but he
recently i think not too long ago he
died well uh yeah i think it was a few
years ago actually yeah
yeah and what was it what do you know
about him well not very much other than
i i was interested enough um in him to
to check out some of
his presentations and some of his his
interviews
and um he had i think he had deep
appreciation
and knowledge about uh the difference
between real food and fake food
um but um you know as you know uh eddie
um i have great appreciation
for um the um uh what
what what what i um uh uh describe
as um uh the spectrum of possibilities
for human metabolism there is no one
diet that is right for everybody so
you're on a different what we call meth
this is like a school of thought i like
your school
what your school of thought promotes is
that it's not a one-size-fits-all that
makes sense so what
yeah one man's food is another man's
poison could be yes
yes that was identified several thousand
years ago by the roman thinker lucretius
and
you know where is the evolution in
consciousness you know so that's your
method of your school of thought
and and and someone you know who's
promoting
um a particular um diet or
or nutrition plan you know for for
everybody one particular approach is not
someone i'm i'm very interested in
um and dr
sebby seemed to me from the
presentations and interviews that i
heard him give
that he had a very strong
bias i think is the appropriate word
for vegetarian eating and that works
well for some people but certainly not
everybody
you know there are in fact the vast
majority of people that i
work with they experience the best
results
in building their health enhancing their
health
when they eat when they find the right
balance for them
of of of of plant foods and
animal foods but the vast majority of
people that i work with do best when
they do
include some high quality animal protein
and animal fat in their nutrition plan
especially um when it comes from healthy
humanely raised that's what we have to
make clear
because a lot of times many of any
studies or anything that
people point out you will get eventually
sick if you're eating from sick animals
these these from farm from the
conventional industry
it's this it's just thinking logically i
mean doesn't doesn't that
make sense you know if you if you take
the time to think things through for
yourself
you know if you're if but you couldn't
go wrong i mean somebody so
he was he he was doing some good work uh
so he ended up dying in jail there was
someone they say that he
had found a cure or he was on his way or
something like that
regarding aids and there was some
success
in it and i don't know if someone even
mentioned magic johnson or whatnot
going through him did you hear about
that um no i don't
so and anyways he ends up um and
we i mean we believe that the creator
got almighty for every disease he sent a
cure
yes but we haven't in in this industry i
remember you telling me we haven't cured
anything in over 100 years there's no
well
you know that's the conventional
rockefeller medicine
you know that's you know they're a big
part of their
of their business model is like you
mentioned chris before
you know who is um uh you're you're one
of your patients
someone someone that i give guidance to
you know i don't like the word
patient for one thing i'm not a doctor
nutrition and health educator
the second thing is you know the word
patient means to suffer
so um in fact you know what i was
listening to i found i found a doctor
um recently um
on on youtube uh his name is dr
stephen hodzi and um he's got a wellness
center
uh down in texas and you know what i i
he refers to all of the the people that
come to this house health center
not as patients he refers to them as our
guests
as a guest isn't that isn't that lovely
yeah
our guest and and he teaches uh
his guest he what he's doing down there
is basically what we were doing at
at the optimal wellness center was you
know we were teaching people that really
the best way to overcome what you could
call
the darkness of disease or dysfunction
is to
is to turn up the light of your inner
health we
we taught our our all of the people that
came to us at the optimal wellness
center in the glory days of the optimal
wellness center
basically how to eat healthier how to
live healthier this is
this is what we call this is like taibat
this is like you mentioned halal there's
another
aspect of eating
real food organic food pure food this is
what
we should be eating and you talk about
that so i mentioned dr subby because he
ended up
uh having some success people are saying
that he had some success
then he got started getting a lot of
heat because of that there was someone
that was nipsy or some some um
like hip-hop artist was uh also
going to him he was really impressed
with him
and then he ends up he was going to put
a documentary together this nipsey about
dr sebi
about his work to highlight his work so
he's kind of a big name in the hip-hop
industry
this nepsi if i'm saying it right i kind
of i'm not i don't listen to the
hip-hop or any of this stuff anymore but
this was this is um
uh big news so then he ends up also
getting killed
why do i kill all holies i'm not i'm not
saying there's anything behind it but
i'm
just highlighting it because but then it
goes back to some of the things that
that we found uh you mentioned dr
nicholas gonzalez
um he was someone who had some success
in treating cancer
yes and other doctors are using a
nutritionist and then it doesn't take a
sherlock holmes and you think hold on
man we see
like what's going on here and these
people like they're coming up they're
doing some work
and all of a sudden you know they end up
dead yeah right yeah a conspiracy now is
if we start conspiring we say oh what
happened like this this i'm just
i'm just asking a question just like you
don't need to be sherlock holmes it's
like
people when they're they're on the road
to you know maybe coming up with
something
of a cure or then they end up all of a
sudden a heart attack what happened with
nicholas gonzalez
people can look him up he was a
brilliant mind
he also had the most documented success
most documented
scientific now he's documenting his
stuff yeah and and he had the most
documented success
of any practitioner in the country in
helping people to realize
freedom from various types of
malignancies
with a nutrition-based holistic program
i remember and he was a student
he was following first he went in if i
remember when i was uh looking into him
he was very he was very skeptical he was
going into going to go into medical
school he was a
investigative journalist or something
right he was and then he was like
looking at this like these people are
quacks
he started uh was it dr kelly that's
right dr kelly said look in my files go
ahead just
look he had hundreds of hundreds of
files of success stories
he said go ahead go examine him go ahead
and he started to
examine it he's like man this is this is
science this is science i mean this is
like proof
and then he got pulled in and he started
to you know follow his method and they
were having success
and then what happened to him well um
after he had been in practice for almost
30 years
in a very high profile location in new
york city
um at the age of 67 as i mentioned
earlier uh eddie before
before we started filming the show that
uh it's
four years ago this month that dr
gonzalez was found dead
um and uh there was no indication that
he had any
any uh health problems didn't they say
heart attack before he died well
um he was autopsied and from my
understanding
i was following his website
for a number of months after he had died
to see what was
being posted and um
he was autopsied and the autopsy did
rule out heart attack he did not die of
a heart attack
but um but that's what they said it
wasn't the cause of death well that was
the assumption that was the assumption
he died he died very suddenly yeah but
the um
uh as far as i know and um you know the
the cause of death was
was indeterminate it wasn't it was it
was not it was not identified i could be
wrong about that
but um you know dr gonzalez um
was getting more and more vocal in the
in the last years of his life getting
getting more and more media attention
for instance
um a very well-known celebrity who's
actually also been the author of a
number of best-selling books
uh the actress the beautiful actress
suzanne summers
had featured
the work of dr nicholas gonzalez and
actually a best-selling book that
that she uh put together um called
knockout which was about um
doctors uh curing cancer
with non-toxic methods and that's susan
that's sam summers
isn't that from that uh what is that uh
she's a famous actress right right
yeah yeah she was in a um in a very
popular uh
tv show back in the in the 70s 80s
but she's um she uh has been writing
about
uh about health issues for uh the last
several decades
and um anyway why did these people
usually get just
like uh dismissed as quacks they just
you know kick them to the curb and say
these people are just
uh there's something wrong with them
yeah um
well um nicholas gonzalez was uh but if
you watch nick
nicholas gonzalez you watch some of his
stuff he's brilliant i mean you can see
him just he's like
anyone nick doctor nicholas gonzalez
look it up look at that oh yeah he's
still there's
many of his presentations dr nicholas
short and long uh on youtube one of the
one of his famous
uh students also dr kelly brogan right
yes doctor kelly bro she was mentored
with him for the last session she's
having tremendous success
yeah uh helping people and it's not with
drugs she does p
she helps people with food now she was
uh uh she's a psych was
uh she's a psychiatrist psychiatrist and
they prescribe the most drugs
yeah she's she specializes in women's
psychiatry
and um up until about seven or eight
years ago
she was basically very conventional just
writing prescriptions for
you know what with the diagnosis minimal
success minimal success yeah well she's
almost no success she saw that she
wasn't really helping people in the long
run but she
she was being very successful in
practicing the business of
of psychiatry but she had her own health
crisis after she had her first pregnancy
and she was diagnosed
with a condition known as i can talk all
about this because she's
very public with her story and she she
she wrote a book in 2015 called
a mind of your own which is basically
it's it's it's that book is basically uh
mostly about how to eat healthier and i
got the book yeah i've read the book yes
right
and so um it's a good book so she's
she's
she's um been doing um
basically nutrition and health educating
work
for the last seven plus years and having
having the the best success of a career
helping
helping women overcome depression and
anxiety and a lot of other so-called
mental emotional psychological issues
but after her first pregnancy
she developed a condition that was
labeled as hashimoto's thyroiditis
and the medical dogma about that as it
is for
almost every type of chronic condition
as well we don't know the cause
and there's no cure but we can give you
drugs and
you know that's that's a business model
that's not medical science it's a
business model
put in place a long time ago by very
very powerful interest
and gets promoted to the public as you
know medical science but anyway
she worked with a
a naturopathic doctor who taught her
about what
real food was and got her on the right
nutrition plan for her and
you know taught her how to eat healthier
and how to live healthier
and although the dogma about hashimoto's
thyroiditis
there's there's no cure for this uh
within a year she was completely cured
of this condition
uh based not only on her own subjective
experience
her health how she was feeling but also
the blood tests there are specific
markers and and blood tests that um
can identify this this condition and uh
you know there's specifically there are
these what are known as thyroid
antibodies that
get elevated when when someone has um
someone has a problem with uh with their
thyroid function and they they get this
this diagnostic label of hashimoto's
thyroiditis
primarily because they have elevations
of of certain thyroid antibodies
um and um and they're also experiencing
um low thyroid function and the symptoms
related to that such as
you know low energy and low mood and
you know other symptoms of underactive
thyroid are constipation
dry skin hair loss
a number of other symptoms can manifest
so you see her she completely overcame
that she overcame that she talks about a
lot of cases now that she
she is actually helping to heal people
from many of these
these uh these by teaching them how to
eat healthier
just eating what we call eating eating
the real food not but not just that
i also lifestyle she talks about
lifestyle it's about lifestyle changes
right
and also sleeping well eating eating
well yeah
moving your body moving your body
exercise these things that are extremely
important this is what dr
sebby also talked about lifestyle
so just connecting that dr nicholas
gonzalez but this one i bring up because
dr nicholas gonzalez
um this happened to him he died it was
four years ago
four years ago i think dr sebi he died
not too long ago
and a lot of celebrities i think michael
jackson and magic johnson and many
celebrities
were gone to him over the years they
were going to him over the years
so this got highlighted because uh of of
him saying he can cure aids but then who
stands in the interest
someone say well why what's if some
people naively can say like well
why would someone stop him why would
anyone if there's a cure for cancer if
there's a cure for
for aids isn't that a good thing yeah
yeah
yeah wouldn't humanity come together to
support these people why would they
think why would they uh
like some some people claim you're gonna
get taken out yeah
you know well um uh
i think it's um it's naive
to think that um the truth is what
dominates
in the world um it's it's it's it's it's
a great tragedy
of life to to come to the realization
that there are um
economic powers and political interests
that
that they have their own agenda and um
uh the truth often gets trampled by
by by you know the most the most
powerful
interest in the in the world think how
much money now let's say dr sebi he did
come up let's just hypothetically if he
did someone like him or someone else dr
gonzalez they
had the cure for cancer how long they've
been trying to cure cancer how long has
it been
that's i think i believe it's a 160
billion dollar industry so just think
logically
how many people would be out of a job
yeah how many organizations would be
shut down
how much money would stop coming in for
the aids pills like for the
for the basically it's uh the pills that
are
that are symptom managing what's going
on with the
with these diseases all these things
would get shut down because you'd have
now
a cure i had a guest come on not too
long ago he said look if
if god almighty is the most justin with
fear he's not going to limit that
cure for a particular people who have
just so much money it's going to be for
everybody
right so the cures are out there but
humanity
humans are the ones wrecking habit
they're the ones stopping it trying to
stop
it from coming out and then i mean like
it does it's not something far-fetched
where people can research
many people have have come out there's a
list of these doctors who are
good human beings who are coming out
trying to help humanity
next thing they're drowned they're
missing what is known as suicide
suicide and then their family is like
why would he commit suicides like why
would you like all of a sudden
jim you have no reason you're healthy
you're going to get you go to get fresh
food every tuesdays and
saturdays and what a few times a week
you're at the farm
you know you're feeling good you know
all of a sudden
jim committed jim commits suicide now
the people that know you they're like
come on there's no way
jim would hang himself so this is what
happened with many of these people
and it's just interesting it just it's
like what's going on
you know so uh well ultimately it
it comes down to you know
where do you put your trust and
i trust my god-given innate intelligence
and inner inner inner capability
to be healthy and or if i if i managed
to
to injure myself like i've done a couple
times recently
um overdoing exercise you know i trust
my
my god-given capability to to heal
to just to strengthen myself where i
have
developed some um some weakness or to
balance myself or
or i'm out of balance you know and so
you know the intelligence to be
healthy is is there we have that in
every cell of our body has this this
incredible
intelligence to know how to produce
energy
and know how to function properly as
long as the cell
is getting all of its needs met
beginning
with all the nutrients necessary to
support
the cellular needs for energy production
and that's the key issue
you know the cells can't do anything
without energy they have the
intelligence is always there
but it's up to us to provide our body
with all of the nutrients that are
necessary
for producing energy and also the
nutrients
that are needed as building blocks for
for new cells for new tissue
so you know if you if you have a damaged
knee or if you have a damaged foot like
my right foot is currently injured i
banged it into a
you know a door frame accidentally
um my body has has an increased need now
for the the nutrients needed to to make
new cells
new healthy cells but it also needs
energy in order to
to do the the clean in a way of the you
know the damaged injured cells and
and replacing them with with new cells
and that's nutrients that the body needs
nutrients beginning
with the oxygen in the air we breathe
remember our most
important nutrient is is
oxygen and that's why we have a constant
need
to breathe to inhale in fact i teach
eddie i don't know that i've ever
mentioned this on the dean show but
um actually our most basic form of
nutrient of nutrition
our most basic form of nutrition is
actually our inhale
we inhale air to get our most important
nutrient
oxygen oxygen certainly is a nutrient
and so
the better you breathe
the better your health in fact i've
shared this with you for uh
quite some time now i don't miss a day
of breathing exercise i do breathing
exercises breathing very important
every every day because you can improve
the breathing through the through the
through the stomach instead of the chest
even probably
even even more basic than that is to
simply
breathe consciously consciously where
you're actually giving
your your your your mental attention
to your your breath to your inhale and
you can you can improve
um the fullness of your inhale and the
completeness of your exhale
if you do give conscious attention to
this and you do there's many different
type of breathing
exercises that you do that you can do um
i do a variety of different breathing
exercises my my favorite one is what i
call
deep breathing leg raises where i i lay
on my back i inhale as fully as i can
through my nose
and then i lift up my legs in good form
and i exhale through my mouth as
completely as i can
and that that feels the best to me
but i do i do a number of other
breathing exercises and my advice to
people is
if you know how to do any type of
breathing exercise have you ever learned
how to do any type of breathing exercise
you know from um because you're a singer
or because of
you you've done yoga or you've done
martial arts or what
if you know of at least one breathing
exercise that you
you feel good with when you do it that
it you feel it helps you to feel
good or makes you feel even better
my advice is prioritize putting the time
into doing that breathing exercise every
day yeah
it's one of those things at least for
five minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes it
costs you a little bit of time
no side effects right right at the end
you'll feel relaxed
well it's the most important i do after
my class we'll do
and i've had my students come up we'll
do right after the class we'll do some
you know uh stretching and some
breathing exercises and people actually
look forward to that yes it's relaxing
and soothing is calming
and people can look up go look at the
benefits of breathing properly and
breathing exercise
and you'll see a lot of different
benefits and know that you
can improve the quality of your breath
yeah and then
that go that's just one component to
healthy
lifestyle and then if you start getting
all these components right
then you're going to have more of a
chance of living a more optimal
healthy life
right rather than just eating all the
fake foods
not getting proper sleep not developing
nutritional integrity
then going and putting more drugs in
your body
and then you wonder why you know you got
all these uh
issues when you're not addressing the
root problem the root cause lifestyle
right so we we uh we've covered a lot i
want to thank you again for being on the
program
well uh you're very welcome eddie and
thank you again for inviting me back on
the dean show
and i hope uh whoever is watching this
program
find some value in it and um you know
god bless all of your viewers god bless
you and your family
and um uh remember uh
nutritional integrity uh you you
you carry that with you everywhere you
go as a as a shield
against fake food and the fake food
unfortunately is everywhere
in our american culture and in other
cultures too
and so um it's um it's really it's it's
not only valuable it's absolutely
it's it's essential to have appreciation
for um developing your nutritional
integrity so
set the bar high for what is acceptable
food and drink for your body and then be
faithful to these standards that you set
for yourself
and this will serve your health very
very well for as long as you're around
beautiful advice thank you very much
okay eddie thank you
thank you jim marlo here on the dean's
show and you heard it honor the gift
that the creator has given us
this vehicle that's there to get us
through life your body's not a garbage
can don't put garbage in it eat real
food avoid fake food and develop that
nutritional integrity as jim marlowe
health educator has shared that
beautiful advice
with us and we'll see you next time
share in the comments below below some
of your takeaways
from this program share and we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you